[Applause]
shot in Hawaii all the jungles in Hawaii
which you loved your who you born in a
way I wasn't born in a while you live
there in San Francisco but I did a lot
of my growing up there so yeah I don't
know I don't think you gave me a big
speech like this is my land a friend
that was San Fran transfer speech
[Laughter]
the cliffs where I was born I was
beautiful
beautiful you know mountain side and
lushness and and we shot in this
beautiful place called Kualoa ranch
where a Jurassic Park the original
Jurassic Park was shot and the ones
after that as well and it was just
amazing but you didn't like you came he
hated it no this is a problem I didn't I
didn't like it at all I mean outside of
the the spiritual ground said she took
me to and that's a song
original
I didn't like the jungle I mean look I
was very happy at the opportunity you
know the kid to work with Jack and
Dwayne you know was amazing but I'm not
an outdoors guy so insects bugs are an
enemy to me and there was a you know we
had a fair share of spiders and
centipedes and he took full advantage of
everybody he plays too much and there's
a level of cool I don't know if you guys
indoors bullying but I don't I think
[Music]
[Music]